sunset overdrive has a lot of guns but
dare to imagine a world where it had
more guns that's the reality we're
bringing you with the weapons pack
available now cool with it you'll
realize your arsenal with four new
weapons that give you more strategic
options and general insanity first up is
the plague bomb which instantly
intoxicates enemies in the area they'll
start vomiting take damage over time and
explode when kill plus they can spread
the disease to others slap on the burn
baby burn amp and add fiery insult to
injury then there's the rager which
fires a confusion inducing cloud that
causes enemies to attack each other and
yes they also explode and kill are you
catching a theme here with the whole
exploding bodies thing next up is the
shield buddy which activates a shield
that protects you and your friends but
also deploys bombs that decimate your
folks that makes it 87% more useful than
any of your other buddies and finally
the multi lock rocket launcher locks on
to up to eight targets release the
trigger to send the Legion of homing
Rockets after equip it with the rocket
man amp so your Rockets can explode into
more Rockets because excessive is always
impressive grab these four weapons right
now for free with the season pass or buy
it separately for $4.99